so if we apply those ideas
the ideas of this part of the world to
another part of the world that's
currently in war
Russia and Ukraine from what you learned
here how do you think peace can be
achieved
in Ukraine oh this can be achieved any
moment it's motivation in this case it's
just one person you just Putin just need
to say that's it you know the ukrainians
they don't demand anything from Russia
just go home that's the only thing they
want they don't want to conquer any bit
of Russian territory they don't want to
change the regime in Moscow nothing they
just tell the Russians go home that's it
and of course again motivation how do
you get somebody like Putin to admit
that he made a colossal mistake a human
mistake an ethical mistake a political
mistake in installing this war this is
very very difficult but in in terms of
what is this what would the solution
look like very simple the Russians go
home end of the end of story
do you believe in the power conversation
between leaders
to sit down as human beings
and agree first of all what home means
because we humans draw lines that's true
I believe in the power of conversation
the big question to ask is where where
do conversations real conversations take
place and this is tricky one of the
interesting things to ask about any
conflict about any political system is
where do the real conversations take
place and very often they don't play
take place in the places you think that
they are but think about American
politics when the country was founded in
the late 18th century people understood
holding conversation between leaders is
very important for the functioning of
democracy will create a place for that
that's called Congress
this is where leaders are supposed to
meet and talk about the main issues of
the day maybe there was a time
sometime in the past when this actually
happened when you had two
factions holding different ideas about
foreign policy or economic policy and
they imagine Congress and somebody would
come and give a speech and the people on
my own on the other side would say hey
that's interesting I haven't thought
about it yes maybe we can agree on that
this is no longer happening in Congress
nobody I don't think there is any speech
in Congress that causes anybody on the
other side to change their opinion about
anything
so this is no longer a place where real
conversations take place
the big question about American
democracy is is there a place where real
conversations which actually change
people's minds still take place if not
then this democracy is dying also
democracy without conversation cannot
exist for long and it's the same
question you should ask also about
dictatorial regimes like you think about
Russia or China so China has the Great
Hall of the people
and will the representatives the
supposed representative of the People
Meet every now and then but no real
conversation takes place there
a key question to ask about the Chinese
system is behind closed doors let's say
in a politburo meeting do people have a
real conversation if Xi Jinping says one
thing and some other big shot thinks
differently will they have the courage
the ability the backbone to say with all
due respect I think differently and
there is a real conversation
or not I don't know the answer but this
is a key question
this is the difference you know between
a a a an authoritarian regime can still
have different voices within it
but at a certain point you have a
personality cult nobody dares say
anything against the leader
and when it comes again to Ukrainian
Russia I don't think that if you get uh
if you somehow manage to get Putin in
zelenski to the same room when everybody
knows that they are there and they
they'll have a moment of of empathy or
human connection and they have no I
don't think it can happen like that
I do hope that there are other spaces
where somebody like Putin can still have
a real human conversation I don't know
if this is the case I I hope so well
there's several interesting Dynamics and
you spoke to some of them so one is
internally with advisors you have to
have hope that there's people that would
disagree that would uh have a lively
debate internally then there's also uh
the thing you mentioned which is direct
communication between Putin and zelenski
in private picking up a phone
rotary phone old school that's I I still
believe in the power of that but what's
uh while that's exceptionally difficult
in the current state of affairs what's
also possible to have as a mediator like
the United States or some other leader
uh like like the leader of Israel or the
leader of another Nation that's
respected uh by both or India for
example that can have first of all
individual conversations and then
literally get into a room together
it is possible I
more generally about conversations is
it goes back a little to what I said
earlier about the Marxist view of
History
um one of the problematic things I see
today in in many academic circles is
that people focus too much on power
they think that the whole of history of
the whole of politics is just a power
structure it's just struggle about power
now if you think
the the Hall of history and the Hall of
politics is only Power
then there is no room for conversation
because if what you have is a struggle
between different powerful interests
there is no point talking the only thing
that changes it is is fighting
um my view is that no it's not all about
power structures it's not all about
power dynamics underneath the power
structure there are stories
stories in human mind
and this is great new if it's true this
is good news
because unlike power that can only be
changed through fighting
stories can sometimes it's not easy but
sometimes stories can be changed through
talking
and that's the hope I think you know in
everything from couple therapy to Nation
therapy
if you think it's power therapy it's all
about power there is no there is no
place for a conversation
but if to some extent it's the stories
in people's minds if you can enable one
person to see the story in the in the
mind of another person and more
importantly if you can have some kind of
of critical distance from the story in
your own mind and maybe you can change
it a little and then you don't need to
fight
you can actually find a better story
that you can both agree to
it sometimes happens in history you know
again French and Germans vote for
generations and generations
now they live in peace not because I
don't know they found a new planet they
can share between France and Germany so
now everybody has enough territory no
they actually have less territory than
previously because they lost all their
overseas Empires but they managed to
find a story the European story that
both Germans and French people are happy
with so they live in peace
I very much believe in this Vision that
you have of the power of stories and one
of the tools is conversations another is
books uh there's some guy that wrote a
book about this power stories he happens
to be sitting in front of me and that
happened to spread across a lot of
people now they believe in the power of
story uh and narrative even even a
children's book too so the kids I mean
it's fascinating how that's
spreads I mean if underneath your work
there's an optimism
and I think underneath conversations is
what I try to do is an optimism that
it's not just about power struggles it's
about stories which is like a connection
between humans and together kind of uh
evolving these stories that maximize hap
or minimize suffering in the world
and this is why
this is like with some of the most
difficult characters around in the world
today
um and with with this basic belief that
by talking maybe we can move them an
inch
uh which is a lot when it comes to
people with with so much power